[Music]
there is a clear
difference between black tie and formal
imma say it again it's a clear
difference between black tie and formal
formal is a suit
black tie is a tuxedo there you have it
hey gq i'm carlene roy
i'm an event planner and this is the
breakdown
first up crazy rich asian
[Music]
closet it looks a little crazy but this
actually is a real live scenario
our company the venue group actually
have planned events
at a private airport for a celebrity
birthday it looks like they are in a
private hangar there's no cost involved
but there is a cost involved with
the actual airplane it looks like they
have g4s in the back and
a few heavy sized helicopters so a g4
g5 would probably run you about eight
thousand dollars an hour
in this heavy helicopter that they are
in that's probably gonna be about five
thousand dollars an hour
so it looks like they are in a sikorsky
helicopter so sikorsky is like
the mother of all helicopters if you
already don't have a private plane or a
private helicopter and you want to book
one
you have to go through a private
helicopter or a private
jet broker just like you have apartment
brokers they actually have brokers for
private aviation so with all major
events not like your mom's event in the
backyard you have to have some sort of
certificate of insurance there is some
sort of
disclaimer that you have to put in place
to do things like this and it's minimum
cost
i would say maybe an extra few thousand
dollars
[Music]
i have no idea how much a boat like this
cost
but what is interesting about it is that
the side of the boat is branded
basically means like it's customized
that would probably cost you
maybe five thousand dollars and all that
is a big ass
vinyl sticker that you put on and you
put off at the end of an event
it's just a big old tank on water so the
event planner is actually bringing in
the fancy the sound the lighting the
confetti so i can see why the cost of
this type of boat
is a little bit more affordable than a
private yacht
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the emotion that every event
planner
lives their life for the client has
arrived they are excited they have this
moment of gaiting
and joy this is super realistic also you
would notice it in the background you
still kind of hear the helicopter
it's probably taken off so you have to
actually land
in a helipad most big boats most big
buildings
already have a helipad there and
clearance to land
but in some occasions a venue won't have
a helipad but you can arrange one
with the local flight agencies
[Music]
[Applause]
loading is a very important part of
event planning that's when you actually
bring
all the materials all the elements into
the actual location or venue
so for something like this they didn't
just like go in the middle of c
and start loading these things in there
they actually probably arranged a slip
which is a whole different cost so a
slip was probably maybe like five ten
thousand dollars which is basically a
parking space for a boat
and at the slip is where they did their
load in something that all event
planners have to pay for
and that's how they got all the elements
onto the boat cargo ship
or a barge is not the most pristine
type of boat on the inside so i'm sure
they had to do a lot of pre-production
before they actually
loaded in but prior to that they
probably also did
renderings to scale so that they made
sure that before they loaded in
it actually was going to look how they
wanted it to look
these girls that you see they did not
just pull up at the boat just around in
the neighborhood and came to this big
ass boat
these women had to be arranged you
either worked with
a chick wrangler or a modeling
agency to get all these girls there and
that is a fee
i have myself probably spent upwards of
twenty thousand dollars to get
hot girls in the party
for this big old bazooka gun if they
didn't order it from amazon
like the rest of the world i'm sure the
entertainment company they got the
confettis and the chicks and the water
that's something that they would rent to
them for the duration of the party
i would hate to see what the sound and
lighting
line item was for this scene
i'm looking at all the led screens
basically it's like the brightest
biggest projection there is i'm sure
that they probably spent
upwards of two hundred thousand dollars
just in sound and lighting and also
because there's so much power that's
involved with this
they probably had to also get a few
generators you also need a generator
when you have a lot of
electricity going on because if you try
to plug into the house system
you'll crash the whole system for an
event like this i think it should take
you at least 30 days to get it off the
ground we usually have
a 14 day window to plan these very high
profile
big budget events if we get an event
where we have 30 days to plan it then
it's like
god has shined a light down on us it's
very rare that we get that much time
most people who are that jet set
celebrity
type of industry they don't care about
time they don't care about restrictions
that's why they hire people like
us to get the job for them they just
want it done and that just
comes with the business with being an
nick what event you worried about you
have to keep rachel happy he's just
lucky to be
here nice eddie oh
what because the bachelor is from a rich
well-to-do affluent family i'm sure that
they can't have
no bad press that comes out about what
he's doing in his personal life
i'm sure the event planner had to
arrange some sort of non-disclosure
agreements or
confidentiality agreements so the
debauchery and all the fun that was
happening on the boat
didn't get out or get leaked to the
press in addition to the confidentiality
agreements
i'm sure everybody also had to sign a
waiver
that means if you come on here and you
bust your ass or if you fall
overboard we are not liable and this is
all on you so these are some of the
things that you have to take into
consideration
if you are planning an event for someone
that is high net worth or someone that's
high profile
most everyday people are not going
through these extra precautions but
safety first is always our motto so my
overall assessment for the crazy rich
asians bachelor party
is they probably paid three million
dollars the most expensive event that we
have ever planned
was a anniversary event for a very rich
man i think we spent anywhere from
20 to 25 million dollars everybody flew
private
everybody's selling on yachts and also
we had a private concert one night and
we actually built a skating rink in the
middle of the sand desert
that's your budget right there next up
the great gatsby
the whole city packed into automobiles
and
all weekend every weekend the pull-up
is crazy but what you don't see in this
scene right here are
valet attendants so you see all these
dope cars
all these people all this commotion that
has to be organized you want
tons and tons of valet attendance
because you don't want these people
waiting so you want to make sure that
you
over staff at an event like this at a
house party
you will probably find a location that's
less than a mile away
hopefully closer than that that has some
sort of big lot or big
area where you can park all the cars
must have ballet at a party like this
[Music]
if the party is playing right it'll be
very difficult for an unwanted guest or
a party crasher to enter a party like
this
at most house parties at big lavish
houses something like what's in this
movie you will have
several checkpoints if you ain't even on
the list you wouldn't even be able to
approach the actual
house i see party crashers all the time
you name it i've seen it i've seen
people
scale buildings i've seen people jump
over
brick walls i've seen people pop outside
of a trunk
but guess what they can do all that
extra they want if they get to the front
and they're not on the list they're not
getting in before i became an event
planner and i worked for diddy to help
him curate the guest list and that takes
some
finesse that takes knowing how to
wrangle the right people
in a room a good party you want a mix of
personalities you want a mix of guests
film stars broadway directors
morality protectors high school
defectors and
ewing clip springer dubious descendant
of
beethoven that's what you need that is
the variety and diversity that makes a
party dope the guest list and having the
right people in the room
is key when i work for diddy and of
course because he is who he is
all these people he had on speed dial
and in his phone
i would be inviting these superstars
texting them
emailing them directly nowadays the
organizer is probably working with
a talent wrangler or the publicist or
the manager of talent
[Applause]
[Music]
when you are planning a party in
someone's home you take a lot more
care into it because it is actually
their house so you are taking a lot more
precaution with
how you move the furniture you actually
are inventorying everything like the
couch was here in room
a the vos was here in room b so you
really are
handling things with a fine-tooth comb
you always want
entertainment at a party like this it
just keeps more
things visually for the eyes to see when
they're in the room
so dancers like this the costume the
makeup
let's say for maybe 10 or so dancers
that probably was anywhere from 20 to 25
thousand dollars
just for dancers and the dancers usually
work on a
two hour set
i love the lighting in this film because
it feels very grand
and whenever you have an event the
lighting has to be perfect because the
lighting
changes the mood a good event planner
knows how to change the mood
throughout the evening and also once you
invest a lot of money
into your event the food the decor
all the elements you don't want the
party so dark where your guests actually
can't see
what is happening in the venue i think
your lighting line item will probably
run you anywhere from
a hundred thousand dollars to two
hundred thousand dollars
modern time alone and a little
embarrassed
i decided to get roaring drunk
one thing i like about this film is that
there is a surplus of staff you see a
million people pouring champagne
you see a million people with hors
d'oeuvres and that
is just called over hosting your guests
you never want your guests to wait
you never want to feel like when is the
next meatballs coming by like you want
to
always keep the food always want to keep
the drinks
going carrying inheritances on gatsby's
beach
i just want everybody to look at how
much they are
drinking they are spending a load amount
of money
on just food and beverage and that is
the one of the most expensive line items
for
any event any party once you pay for the
venue the most expensive thing is always
your catering catering can be hundreds
of thousands of dollars
especially for an event at this scale
and knowing gatsby
they wasn't drinking no whale drinks
they are drinking the finest
top shelf liquor there is and that also
is always the most expensive
liquor package you have and this is open
bar keep in mind
this takes place in the 20s but a
catering
and bar line item these days for what
they're doing is probably at least
two hundred thousand dollars
[Music]
his smile was one of those rare smiles
the fireworks have to be scheduled in
advance
for most cities you have to schedule
your fireworks or get your firework
permit at least seven days
in advance not like you going to party
city and just getting some fireworks
like
these are like real deal professional
fireworks that have to be launched
by a professional for novelty splash
things like this i think
short and quick is the best way to do it
i would say
fireworks show like this probably cost
you anywhere from
15 to 25 000
again this party took place in the 20s
so i would say in today's time they
probably spent around
5 million to pull this off next up
step brothers you guys seem to be
hitting it off
oh honey oh my god this is the greatest
party an event like this
especially like a wine mixer you don't
have to do much
just let the scenery and the vibe speak
for itself like the grounds is beautiful
the sun is beautiful like that is the
scene already
the purpose of a wine mixer is to
educate yourself
on the different wines in a more festive
setting
so you're there to try probably flights
of wine and a flight of wine is
basically
a sample of a bunch of different wines i
like this party because it's low fuss
you don't have to do a lot of work so if
you notice from the setup
it's very simple they have six foot
tables high boys
picnic wicker type you know soft
furniture so it's not a lot of bells and
whistles that goes on with this
it's very nice to see you robert i think
i think brennan organized this whole
thing to get us back together
you also notice at this type of event
the music is
low enough where people actually can
talk and have a conversation so you
never want the music
too loud at this type of event where
it's so loud that you can't hear what
people are saying
if you are ever trying to save money a
beer and wine package is the way to go
because it is the most economical bar
package that you could have
at any event let's say at an event for
150 to 200 people
a beer and wine package would probably
cost you about 84
per person whereas an open bar top
shelf type of event would cost you 200
250
per person guys this is supposed to be
jicama not bok choy
sorry folks you will see the style of
how the food is served
is way casual so it looks like it's
buffet style
where they have servers actually serving
the food and the buffet line to guests
the guests then take their play and go
sit at their tables and it's no assigned
seating
you sit where you want like this is a
very low fuss
low brow type of way to serve food to
your guests a buffet is always gonna be
cheaper than a plated formal meal
hey brandon good to see you dale thanks
for hiring our canyon company
easy decision you guys have an
outstanding tracker
don't get food every catering company
and every chef
is not the same you want to work with a
catering company that is tried and true
and that is a line item that you don't
want to skimp on so
make sure that you are vetting who your
caterer is
very rarely will i hire a caterer that i
never work with for a big event i would
probably test them out on a small event
first
to see how they show up and how they
produce and if they pass the test for
the small event
maybe i'll give them another chance to
do a bigger event with us
we are california's preeminent 1980s
billy joel cover
cover bands are the worst i don't know
why people hire
cover bands like it's just like the
epitome of like
cheesy weddings a no for me
hey listen we only sing 80s dog i'll
take your skank hook your wife and get
out of here
if there was a fight between a guest and
a higher staff
i would try to handle it as discreet as
possible because you never want to make
a scene
and you never want the guests to see you
sweat would defuse the situation
maybe pull them to the side and whoever
is at fault that person got to go and
that is when security steps in
you cost me money so this isn't even a
judgment call man
you're outta 5 000 my friend dear can we
talk about this
is everything okay no he just fired me
an event planner wouldn't be fired on
the spot for something like this because
the event planner still needs to see the
event through like get through the rest
of the event
but i highly doubt if that client will
hire them again
okay here's the thought i see an empty
stage
i see drums i see a drummer i see a
microphone
and i see a singer dad come on what who
gave that stuff
up prices happen in live events all the
time that's nothing new but one thing i
would never
do as an event planner is solicit
another guest
to step in after entertainment because
the band just
up and left for whatever reason what i
would do in this scenario
is take my phone go to wherever the
little control area is for the music
and play some sort of playlist anything
so that there is not dead silence and
that the party could continue to go and
the guests don't know
anything about it there is nothing worse
that if you're at a party and you're
dancing and having a good time and then
the music says
it's like the worst thing that could
ever happen i have been in events where
the music has went out we did offset's
birthday party in
l.a last year and the music went out and
i saw offset
jump over a million people to get to the
dj booth and ask the dj what the hell is
going on
i've had events where the band was so
terrible that i literally had to pull
the plug like yo y'all's time is a wrap
so things with the music and hiccups
like that happens all the time
that is why you have a sound check to
make sure that the transition is always
cool
and that's why you have plenty of
generators to make sure there ain't no
power issues
[Applause]
[Music]
so you only see ice breaking or glass
breaking in movies but it's something
that
actually happens if the music is so
robust
if it's so strong in actuality will
break the glass and that is where your
damage fee come in and that's where
having good insurance comes in because
you just clean it up and you keep going
about your business
we were doing an event with quavo from
migos and there was one scene
at the event where we had glasses on the
shelf
and as we were running through the
rehearsal for the event
and doing the sound check the music was
so robust
it was so strong that it broke all the
damn glass
it came shattering to the ground we had
a few hours before
doors out open but in the end we
replaced it and it all worked out
my final thoughts on this catalina wine
mixer is
they probably spend anywhere from 150 to
200
000 next up ocean's 8.
this is spot on for the met gala and
shout out to whoever organized this
because i'm sure they had to get the
blessing of
vogue the met the city to recreate this
whole
iconic scene which is such a cultural
moment
in hollywood so the way they did this
chef's kiss
that is the press pit so that's where
all your paparazzi is
that's where you have people doing
commentary for
media outlets also like this because you
are press and paparazzi there's a dress
code for you
as well so you will notice that all of
the photographers
are in black tie as well as the people
who are interviewing the celebrities as
they come up steps
you just can't pull up because you have
on a tuxedo and
a camera they have to come with their
own clothes they have to have their own
tuxedo
it's nothing that the met gala is
dressing them for they ain't the
celebrity
okay your name uh hindu schneider
oh here it is
now this part to me is not realistic
okay if this is a general check-in list
the check-in would have happened
outside of the tent or outside the
entrance
you don't want to give party crashers or
people who are not invited the
opportunity to even step
foot inside the party if they don't want
to be there so i'm assuming because the
med gal is so on point that this is
probably the second or third
check-in before talent goes up the
famous steps
next we have serena williams how are you
i'm good hurry i'm good thank you so
you've conquered the court you've
conquered motherhood
for a red carpet event there is some
coordination that goes involved
with it if there's a budget you usually
are sending a car for the talent
to come you're arranging with them how
many people
are in their party or are they coming
with security is security allowed inside
for the med gala it doesn't look like
they allow
talent to come with security which most
big celebrity events don't allow because
you have so much damn security there
they spend a million dollars
on security probably so wrangling talent
and having talent arrive
at a red carpet it's definitely a
science so for just any run-of-the-mill
red carpet
even they show up when they show up they
get a notice this is the time that the
red carpet opens
this is the time that the red carpet
closes if they want their photo taken
they gonna show up between that window
for something as orchestrated as the med
gala
i'm sure that they give a notice to the
talent in advance of a window of time
kim kardashian you need to arrive
between 7 and 7
15 so that it's not so jumbled on the
carpet
hedges have to be custom and when i say
custom because
the hedges have to go along the vibe of
the steps or the shape of the actual
steps and that cream carpet that you see
that carpet is not there every day so
that carpet has to be cut
it has to be laid it has to be installed
it has to be broken down and right
before the guests come
you see the people vacuum in the carpet
to make sure there is not a spot on it
so the outside
entry alone carpet hedging
tinting the velvet drapes we probably
looking at and the lighting probably
300 000 or more
you will see that the lighting mood has
changed already
we do events in phases or in stories
like story a's 3b
for their rivals it was very bright you
saw spotlights because
people are getting their photos taken
and now you can see which looks like
phase b it's a bit more moodier because
they're probably set in the scene for
what is happening next
dinner or performance
[Music]
so this looks like your standard
reception style
or dinner style setup area you would
notice that you have
small florals on each table you want the
florals either
small and low or high and skinny and
that is because you want to be able to
see the people that you actually are
talking to as you are eating dinner for
florals such as this they're not over
the top they're not too crazy it's just
florals and some tea lights
that probably is like 150 to 200
a table just on that small white floral
arrangement
they probably work with the fine china
vendor to get them the china settings
and that can run you
let's say for a 200 person dinner
probably
17 000 in china alone
the met gala is dope for two reasons one
is just such a beloved sacred event
second because it's in the metropolitan
museum of art so it means you have
so much high quality high priced
art there so the art in conjunction with
the fashion that is the theme for that
year's event
i mean the security around not touching
all of that stuff alone is like i can't
even wrap my head around it
most security guards cost anywhere from
50 to 65
dollars an hour and looking at the
security guards that they have for this
event
i'm sure they blew the budget on
security and they also have put in place
subtle security measures so that you
also can like see the art and see the
beauty of the garments
but also it's not like a construction
like don't touch sign so it's a way more
chic way to
protect the art and the garments
hi everybody how are you
hi
the met gala is known for being like so
pristine and the secrecy of like what's
happening in the inside if you don't get
invited then you just don't get invited
so there are a few security measures
that you can put in place so that
your event is not photographed for
people who doesn't need to see if you
can do a phone check-in
they'll walk through a metal detector so
it's not like they can hide it and then
they will have to
give their phone you put it in a lock
sleeve and that they put it almost like
in a cubby or a locker
you also can put up wide notices around
that says like please no photography
no posting during this time for
something like this
i would assume that's what they do here
because it'll be pretty hard to get
these celebs
in the world of instagram not on their
phone also
the met gala is so gangster and people
want to get invited again i'm sure
they're not gonna try
to like sneak photos because they want
that invitation i'm guessing
for a fancy high class event like this
that the tables for
eight guests probably run you about
three hundred thousand dollars
all in all oceans eight met gala budget
i think we're looking at about
three million dollars next up spectre
this is very much about the city the
vibe the energy
and just community and culture to do an
event like this or to hold an outside
festival like this
you have to get permits for the streets
you have to get permits for
the sidewalks and all of this has to be
organized through
the mayor's office so you would work
with the events department to get the
proper permits
this scene takes place in mexico cities
but in
the u.s specifically new york city a
permit would probably cost you around
one thousand dollars a day i actually
think that this movie
inspired mexico city create an actual
day of the dead celebration because it
was just like such a frenzy around this
scene in the movie
i have personally never made a float but
i do know that there are fabricators
fabricator is someone who can custom
build
custom create things looking at this and
just the scale
and intricacy of it this looks like it
probably costs at least
thirty thousand dollars to create this
and most floats are housed
in like a warehouse and it's a whole
storage situation that goes into it
there is a few mechanics that goes
probably into the cost what the real
cost in this type of parade
is crowd control security
restrooms and cleanup that is where the
bulk of the money is going
so the city is not paying for the lavish
costumes or the makeup and all that
people are paying for that on their own
again the key thing with any type of
mass
gathering is permits and crowd control i
cannot stress that enough
safety is first you want to make sure
that there is a clear pan
to get people in and out areas of egress
so you would work with your security
and you will probably work with the
local precinct to make sure that those
measures are in place
in this scene you see them going down
this massive street but you also see it
looks like
buildings or residencies or companies on
both sides
tenants that are occupying those
businesses they need to be working in
concert with
the police and the security department
so they're probably going to be closed
for business because i don't know how
much
they want to be involved with the frenzy
but they need to be on board with what's
happening
in the community in the vicinity as well
also
anytime there is a festival or a parade
or something big like this happening in
town
best believe that whatever the
neighboring hotels are they are
up charging for those days probably
double the price
for hot ticket weeks like this
next up office christmas party
this looks like a tragedy like i would
never want to
plan an event like this um
a mess clearly there is no event planner
for this party they definitely ain't
called me
to do nothing like this
we do have some corporate clients we
work with netflix we work with
youtube we work with google and they
never have christmas parties like this
thank god keep going
[Music]
it didn't look like they spent a lot of
money on this event but looking at this
ice slide contraption and this ice
sculpture i think that's where the bulk
of their money went
and an ice sculpture something like that
probably cost them around
five thousand dollars if i had to guess
i've seen ice luge before
and it seems like the most unsanitary
thing in life i don't know why people
want to participate in it like please
somebody tell me
i think ice sculptures ice anything is
so
dated just period let me just say that
but you definitely can bring
in an ice sculpture to any type of
building any type of venue
most ice sculptures come with some sort
of like bin
to catch the actual water that's leaking
from it so that it doesn't
spread throughout the event venues one
thing to keep in mind with ice
sculptures
the heavier it is you need to get
clearance
for the actual building to make sure
that it's strong enough to actually hold
it
we do tons of parties with rappers and
we did one event with offset from migos
and he wanted to have a bentley truck
ice sculpture this ice sculpture it was
actually the same weight as an
elephant and we had to get clearance
from the venue to actually
bring it in it was a whole situation it
wasn't too crazy but it was a few
thousand dollars the ice slot in this
scene is probably the craziest thing
i've ever seen
i'm sure that they have some sort of
contraption
or situation to actually catch the
actual water that was melting from the
slide
because i'm sure with them drinking and
being drunk and sliding on an ice slide
there is
water all over the place like that is
like
damage 101. there is really no way to
calculate
damages for a party to the nose but a
good event planner knows to have a 10
contingency line item your contingency
line item is for
overages extras that come up that you
may not know of
and then also is to cover any damages
anything that happened at the event that
was unforeseen
so always budget in a 10 contingency
line item so that you cover
all of these costs and you don't have to
go back to your client to ask them for
more money damages can be anything from
cigarette burn to tearing up a floor
from nail polish being poured on a
persian rug you
name it i have seen the damages and
guess what that's just the cost
that we're going to have to eat and pay
for at the end of the event
[Music]
there are levels to having a photo booth
at your event it can go from as cheap as
500 to upwards of 10 000
in the days of instagram everybody wants
to outdo everybody with their
photo booth activation but you can see
in this scene they have a very
generic photo booth this probably cost
you around 800
900 for a party overall with this party
i think they spent no more than 50 000
next up meet joe black
this looks like the ideal venue because
it looks like it's already
an amazing structure you see it looks
like the lights already live there
the great sprawling lawn like those
things are already there so those are
elements that you don't have
to pay for so if you can find a venue
that already has a panache with it
it's less work that you have to do to
design it out
as an event planner outside events are
completely beautiful but you always have
to keep the weather in mind a good event
planner
always has a rain plan in place so
if you're looking for an outside venue
you want to make sure that it is
transitional
should it be rain or should it be cold
at night does this event location
lend me putting up a tent or having tons
of people with umbrellas like these are
things you should be looking at or
thinking about in the back of your mind
and also as the event planner you're
going to be checking the weather that
we like crazy and the call or the best
practice for calling if you're going to
transition to your rain plan is usually
24 hours in advance is when you say
we're doing our rain plan or not you
need 24 hours because you actually want
to give
ample time to get the tents loaded and
get them to the venue and so that they
can be erected
in time
i thought i was going to sneak away
tonight
this style event is what we would call
like gala style
or banquet style you see very
traditional round tables
everybody is dressed up you have a big
band on the stage
someone is giving remarks this style is
something that is tried and true
and very classic nailing the style of
the event
is the first thing that you want to get
as a client when you are
working with somebody
i am the queen of a dress code because
if somebody come in and the outfit is
not right
they got to go there is a clear
difference between
black tie and formal imma say it again
it's a clear difference between black
tie
and formal formal is a suit black tie is
a tuxedo
there you have it formal is a long dress
for a woman
maybe it doesn't have all the
embellishments and bells and whistles
and black tie is more gown and style
more
embellishments more bells and whistles
more jazzy more
razzle dazzle this is quintessentially a
black tie event
the gentlemen have on tuxedos and the
women have on long gowns
your security needs to know that like
anybody not within the dress code
they can't get in there's a time and a
place for everything so with the music
in particular
at a black tie event like this you don't
want to turn up
too easy you kind of want to ease your
way into it so
maybe the music is a bit softer you know
a bit more
chill the night increases then it's when
you really have people
rocking on the dance floor so i think
the bones of this venue
was already existing like it already
lived there before they got there
i do think this gazebo structure was
actually
built and designed in mind with the
spirit of the venue because it kind of
looks like it already goes but we know
that they built this out for this
birthday party
there's a few things that goes into
having a live band so this is a big band
it probably looks like at least
30 people so you have to pay one for
all the back line all the extra
equipment
and sound that a band actually needs to
perform
live so the back line plus the actual
cost of the band for this alone that
probably was close to i would say like
maybe fifty thousand dollars
not all cakes are real cakes so
a lot of times event planners will get a
faux cake made which is a fake cake and
the cake has
nothing in it this cake in particular
100
is a faux cake the top tier is probably
real and that's where they put the
candle in you blow in the candle
you take it away but meanwhile behind
the scenes you have
a sheet cake that's already cut up in
squares
and ready to go to be served to the
guests the face ic
is a memory it may not be a perfectly
perfect memory uh
sometimes we had her ups and down one
thing that this gentleman did
really well is that he addressed the
crowd during the event
if people are getting dressed up if
people are traveling town
good manners is that the host will
always give remarks
thanking the crowd for attending their
birthday party so bravo for him for
doing this
this event was a bit more formal from
what we see
they not turn it up too much it's not so
crazy they already have a beautiful
venue
i would think that they spent no more
than 750 000
on this party all in all these movies
that we saw today
i think that they were spot on nothing
seemed too crazy or over the top that i
have never experienced
myself as an event planner and my number
one rule i would say what makes a party
a party is
the energy and the spirit of the people
in the room you can be at the world's
classiest event during the cannes film
festival or you can be at a dive bar in
a lower east side
but now you know we've had to make some
pivots and some changes so we can still
gather but now you have to gather in
small groups and we have to just take a
bit more extra precaution some things
that event planners are doing now is
you're having a covet officer on site
someone to take
temperatures someone that can do rapid
testing you know
before you used to tell people to like
get dressed up and this is the dress
code
so now we're actually helping them with
the dress code like we're gonna create
some very fly
masks for you and let's make your mask
go with your outfit setting up
sanitation
stations around your location or your
venue so there are smart ways to host
a small group of people but keep safety
and precaution
and social distance in mind we don't
want to miss out on
life's milestones during this moment but
we also want to be smart about it
gq i had the best time hanging out with
y'all today watching these movie clips
so
until next time